hello there it's another week in the
past fortnite OG the season that led us
travel back to 2018 has jumped forward
once again to the events of season 9 and
season X and the world is destabilizing
fast the event countdown is now in the
sky as chapter 5 and the Big Bang live
event approach fortnite storyline is
getting blown apart and a Lego crossover
bigger than anyone expected is coming we
have a lot to get through starting with
the story
line we've reached the final 10 days of
chapter 4 and our visit to the original
Island this season was all about Jonesy
being sent back in time to Heist
something or someone using a magical
time machine we stole from an ancient
vampire man fortnite is weird alongside
that time machine our weekly recordings
from Dr Sloan herself who remained in
the present what became apparent each
week is that her version of the future
isang changing ripples in time caused by
Jones being here something as
inconsequential as a Mario Kart banana
skin could change reality in unexpected
ways our Jones has not only reached the
scientist rocket he's attached The Time
Machine onto that Intergalactic
spaceship and like usual Sloan has left
a message Sloan here I've definitely
left this message many times before so
get right to it huh this is the first
time in countless lifetimes that I don't
know what happens next we're both
heading off into the unknown I guess
this is goodbye for this me and that you
but we'll meet again reality is not done
with us yet keep the campfires burning
Jones wherever and whenever you go this
really does feel like the end of a
storyline doesn't it Sloan's Deja Vu is
down to the path Jones is taking even
the smallest change in this time period
ripples forward the butterfly effect in
real time we saw this happen last update
I wasn't around because I was really ill
sorry about that when Jones drove the
time machine but slid out and crashed
into loot Lake forcing him to drag that
machine across the water which then
caused the return of Kevin the cube and
his amazing flying powers but did you
take the time to look at the water
underneath there's a blue glow there the
zero point is still here as one fortnite
season is bleeding into another it seems
that the zero point never cracked in
this timeline which means right now in
game both the cube and the orb are
within touching distance I really should
bring up another faction we haven't
spoken about in a long time because they
are within meters of controlling reality
that Cube belongs to the last reality
let's put a pin in that I'll break that
down in a law video coming very
soon meanwhile the time machine is not
only over to the scientist rocket from
season X it's now strapped to it and
let's take a moment to look at those
straps this has to be the weakest part
of Jones's plan an Intergalactic time
traveling spaceship held together by
duct tape and a bit of material perfect
and now we have a time frame for the
interstellar Heist a not so subtle
countdown above Dusty counting down the
seconds to blast off another huge update
this week sees the meteor from season X
return and once again it Stood Still
Frozen in Time moments before it impacts
but wait the impact is already there
underneath it the original Crater from
the visitor is here and the original
meteor from the scientist is here this
season is so full of time paradoxes it's
tough to keep up with anyway on board
that meteor is none other than the
sleeping pod for the scientist the most
lovable member of the seven an
Intergalactic group of peacekeepers with
one purpose in mind to free the zero
point and all of reality you know the
thing that's literally out in the open
right now which anyone could take when
the scientist first arrived back in 2018
he created that rocket which would
locate the zero points position and
ultimately find a way onto the the
bridge but all that is quite redundant
now and that's where Jones comes back
into the story it's now his job to
either deceive or convince the scientist
that he's from the future and he's a
member of the seven and he needs to help
with the plan that's a tough sell I
can't back this next part up with
anything in particular but what about
instead of building the brutes from
season X the scientist builds a suit for
agent Jones making him either somehow a
reskin of the visitor or more likely the
legend the title he's wanted so very
long since first joining the sevens
cause after all they do call me the
legend uh-huh let's keep counting down
the hours to launch another intrusive
thought I have is that we may have all
the clues in front of us already the new
Lobby screen looks familiar to many of
us cast your mind back to season X and
the zero point cracking and exploding
for a few seconds there we were trapped
between realities outside of time I put
it to you that that is what Sloan's plan
is to exist outside of time and open up
the fortnite metaverse no more 22-minute
Loops no more IO no more seven okay I'm
going too far down this Rabbit Hole pull
me back
out let's make sure we have the map
changes for the season covered I'm sure
you've all experienced for yourself the
return of the icy biome but have you
stopped off at Granny's house
crackshot's cabin is back in the game in
its OG Style and inside the Christmas
tree is already up and presents are here
A whole month before Christmas do me a
favor be honest has someone in your
household put up a Christmas tree
already anyway this ties into the
opening cinematic for that very OG
season thinking back that was the season
that Santa Claus became a bad guy in
fortnite did that story ever get
finished like I mentioned earlier the
banana that caused Jones to detour
through loot Lake creating the time
anomaly there remains in game just
sitting here there's also a little
Easter egg to the merchant in Avatar who
would always have his precious cabbages
and Cat ruined by team
Avatar my cabbages I'm so lost on how
many collaborations we've had in
fortnite has Avatar been in yet is this
foreshadowing some Airbenders elsewhere
we've seen the return of the pirate
themed stockades complete with cannons
which are always broken when I use them
and did you notice the return of the ice
sculpures in the snow very epic indeed
and have you noticed the bright light in
the sky this season I can't decide if
it's always been there from day one and
I simply didn't notice or it was added
in last week's update please let me know
your thoughts on this and why it's here
and
finally Hut watch well what a bust this
was this season our precious Hut was
never hurt so it never had to rebuild
itself all season it's just sat there
this timeline
sucks epic games have officially
revealed the teaser image for the Big
Bang event oh and you've got to admit it
does look like the space between
realities we talked about earlier on
Saturday December 2nd we'll Venture into
chapter 5 the event will be the biggest
in fortnite history and will feature a
musical performance from Eminem a new
rhythm game mode a racing mode linked to
Rocket league and a crossover with Lego
that's why we see a Lego llama sitting
floating in space on the home screen I
don't know about you but I absolutely
adore Lego epic have stated the event
will be Unforgettable so I think that's
fair to say it won't be a horrible
creative map like the last event a year
ago I still have nightmares about that
one the event will evolve all things as
we know them which should be story and
Law related and finally a memorable
reveal towards the end does anyone want
to guess what that will be I'm calling
it now either the visitor will be
unmasked as Jones or Donald mustard or
Jones will finally become the legend I'm
Legit hyped about this event the event
will support teams of four so be sure to
get your squad sorted ASAP fortnite is
changing yet again Battle Royale will
soon be only one small part of the whole
experience rocket League a permanent
Lego mode and a constantly evolving
metaverse 2018s version of fortnite may
be gone forever but as a platform
fortnite is here to stay have a great
time at the event I'm Adam you're
awesome it's been a pleasure I'll see
you next
[Music]
time